the world of the ancient Mesopotamians
was one that was filled with various
invisible and supernatural creatures
some of which were good but others that
were definitely evil there were Gods
ghosts witches and demons all of whom
were seen as a natural part of everyday
life in this region in ancient times
indeed the existence of demons was
basically taken for granted by the
mesopotamus and there was never a
question whether or not they existed but
rather what should be done if you
actually encountered one in fact there
was quite a complex and developed
demonology in this ancient civilization
one that involved theories regarding the
personalities of different demons how to
interact with them and of course how to
get rid of those that were causing
trouble or malady so for this year's
shocktober we're going to dive into the
fascinating world of demons and ghosts
and evil well supernatural creatures in
ancient Mesopotamia
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I am very excited to say that this is a
big collaboration between four different
creators here on YouTube I am working
together with my friends Dr Justin
Sledge from the channel esoterica Dr
Angela Pucca from Angela's Symposium and
Dr Dan atrell from the channel the
modern hermeticist we will all be making
videos and releasing them today on some
related topics in terms of occultism I
guess but also things like spirits and
exorcisms I will tell you more about
this collaboration at the end of the
video but it is truly a blessing and
such a privilege to be working with such
amazing people that inspire me go check
out their channels they're all amazing
if you haven't already and and check out
their videos which are going to be so so
interesting
now even though there were certainly
many demons in ancient Mesopotamia it's
important to remember that the modern
idea of demon doesn't really correspond
to the way that the Ancients conceived
of these beings the idea of demons as an
exclusively evil creature associated
with the devil that is out to hurt or
possess humans is one that very much
develops with the writers of early
Christianity
ancient people in pre-christian times
had a rather different conception of
demons the word itself demon comes from
the Greek term diamond and a diamond in
ancient Greece was a much more
ambivalent creature basically a diamond
was a spiritual being that stood in
between the gods and humans the gods
were of course the highest beings in
existence and US humans are lower
physical creatures and in ancient
writers such as Plato the diamonds fit
right in between They Are Spiritual
Beings that are more powerful than
humans but not quite Gods as such they
often acted as intermediaries between
the two Realms and could serve as
positive inspiration or as cause for
trouble
diamonds were neither good nor evil they
were both good diamonds and evil
diamonds so while the idea of evil
diamonds did technically exist there was
only one category of this elusive being
and with us have a slightly more complex
perspective here the situation in
ancient Mesopotamia was basically the
same demons could be both good or evil
with different personalities it's not
that any given demon was either good or
bad definitively but they could do good
or evil things their nature wasn't set
in stone but had personalities and
emotions just like other creatures
obviously the mesopotamus didn't use the
Greek word Diamond especially not in
pre-hellenic times instead the Sumerian
word udog or the equivalent Acadian
utoku was used to refer roughly to our
concept of demon today or rather the
ancient Greek concept of demons as long
as we understand that translating it as
demon is a compromise and that we should
keep in mind that this is referring to a
much broader category of beings rather
than the Christian evil creatures that
we associate with the term today
so what were these demons well the
demons were everywhere and they were
seen as the cause behind all kinds of
different issues both personal and
larger societal issues it was demons
that caused illnesses both mental and
physical it was demons that could cause
Strife in general in society it could
affect the crops in the fields demons
that did Evil things which some evil
some demons did was a problem to the
ancient Mesopotamians and they were
feared and they developed ways for
humans to control and get rid of these
creatures as we both see soon to
understand more how they worked I think
it's probably useful to take some
particular examples so demons could be
very ambiguous creatures that could take
on different forms or no form at all but
there are certain famous demon
personalities that had certain
characteristics and personalities and
were associated with certain things one
of the most famous of these demons was
a frightening female demon that was
primarily seen as a great danger to
children and newborn babies indeed the
thing she was most feared for was that
she would stalk mothers and eat their
babies either before or after birth in
other words she is definitely a demon
that represents the dangers of
childbirth and the possibilities of
miscarriage if a mother has a
miscarriage the baby is stillborn or the
mother doesn't survive the birth this is
the work of La mashtu quite an
unpleasant creature these frightening
characteristics and features can also be
seen from depictions of her as she's
often portrayed with a lion's head and
taloned hands clutching snakes and
nursing a piglet the theme of motherhood
is present here but in a kind of Twisted
way
the origins of this demon is uncertain
but one of the names by which he is
known is as the daughter of Anu Anu
being the chief God in the Mesopotamian
Pantheon in other words it seems like La
Master originally came from the world of
gods perhaps a goddess herself but that
she somehow fell from that position to
instead inhabit the world as an evil
demon obviously this was the kind of
demon that people wanted to get rid of
and there were many techniques and
rituals aimed at doing exactly this
complex incantations that would drive
her off connected to this another very
famous and well-known demon in this
context is Pazuzu indeed he is perhaps
best remembered as the demon from the
1973 movie The Exorcist in which he
basically plays the role of the villain
this is quite interesting because while
Pazuzu certainly has a frightening
appearance and some incantations do
describe him as the king of the evil
wind demons he was mostly used as a
protective Spirit particularly against
la mashtu
Pazuzu really looks like a monster he
has the head of a beast with long claws
and four wings but the figure of this
demon would be employed as protection
his head would often be worn by pregnant
women to keep La mashtu away from The
Unborn Child and a statue of him could
be kept in the house or used in rituals
for the same reason quite the opposite
of his role in The Exorcist in other
words aside from these two prominent
characters we also have other more
ambiguous kinds of demons or creatures
that roam the lands of Mesopotamia there
was for example the so-called liliths or
lilithu female spirits of women who died
in childbirth that could roam around as
well as these similar aradat Lily ghosts
of young women who had died unmarried
that now drifted with a wind from the
hills and haunted men at night
many have of course connected these
liliths the etymology of which means
something like a female spirit or demon
with a figure of Lilith in the Bible
sometimes conceived of as the first wife
of Adam
etymologically there's probably a
connection and it's another example of
the influence of Mesopotamian mythology
on the books of the Bible again to
protect themselves against all these
malevolent forces the Mesopotamians used
various techniques of what we could call
Magic
just like in the later Islamic World
basically all magic or occult practices
had a protective purpose it sought the
help from God or Gods from Evil forces
and their influence either to eradicate
an already existing problem or to
prevent something bad from happening to
begin with
there are examples of non-protective
magic too though and the most famous and
prominent example of this is the witch
yes there were witches in ancient
Mesopotamia too Dina constantopoulos
writes that the witch is quote perhaps
best rendered as malevolent magic user
known as kasheptu and Acadian witches
were evil Cosmic beings similar to
Demons that used magic to do evil rather
than for protective reasons they could
hurt or curse people and could be both
male and female even though the female
version is definitely overrepresented in
other words while magic could be used
for good or evil the kasheptu or which
represented the malevolent use of magic
and something that one needed to be
protected from so now that we have a
kind of General overview of some of the
creatures and evil spirits that roam the
lands of ancient Mesopotamia what can we
say about the actual practices used to
ward off these forces I mentioned
earlier that there existed various
rituals and protective
ways that one would counter these evil
forces or get rid of them or at least
control them in some way and this
included fascinating things everything
from incantations protective amulets
exorcisms and various other juicy things
it's definitely true that the
Mesopotamians had developed systems that
were called protective rituals indeed a
lot of such Traditions that we find in
other places later in history such as in
the Greek magical papyri or in Egyptian
and Roman magic may actually originate
in places like Babylonia and Assyria we
have long text written back then about
how to protect oneself from witchcraft
or demons and archaeological findings
also gives us first-hand examples of
what this could look like
at the center of this tradition was a
class of professional exorcists referred
to as ashipu
these were ritual Specialists that could
do everything from divination herbal
medicine and to exercise and banish evil
demons
a pretty important person in a society
in which these forces were omnipresent
the art ship who had a bunch of
different tools and special knowledge
with which he could accomplish this
first and foremost when protection was
sought from evil spirits or misfortunes
this was done from the Gods Not the
diamonds right but the actual Gods who
ruled the world deities like enki Marduk
or Ishtar in other words the ritual
specialist would counter evil spirits by
invoking the power up and seeking the
help of the Gods and he would do so
through spells incantations and magical
objects such as amulets not only do some
of these objects survive but we also
have significant writings which attest
to these practices and even sometimes
give instructions there are very
significant works such as the so-called
Exorcist manual a compendium of
everything that an aspiring professional
needed to know in terms of esoteric
knowledge incantations medical knowledge
and generally how to perform rituals of
exorcism works such as these are
invaluable for our understanding of how
the these magical practices worked in
Antiquity on top of just being
incredibly fascinating in themselves so
say you were being bothered by a demonic
Force perhaps your house was being
haunted or a family member had
mysteriously Fallen ill or you wanted to
protect your baby from the child eating
lamashtu in that case you could simply
call an ashipu who would come and solve
your problem he would and it is mostly
he in these cases show up to your house
and make an assessment of what needed to
be done since ghosts and demons were
such a taken for granted part of
everyday life the vibe here is kind of
similar to people today calling for a
doctor to help with a medical problem
got a demon problem just call your local
ashipu and he will help you out and
indeed in this culture the doctor was
kind of the same person as The Exorcist
since the ashipu could also have medical
knowledge once the demon was identified
or the ashibu knew what needed to be
done he would get to work Gathering all
the materials that were required for the
ritual before it would commence we've
already mentioned some of the details of
the kinds of practices and material that
would be used in these kinds of
exorcistic rituals say for example that
your troubles were caused by a ghost the
spirit of a deceased human being
this could happen for various reasons
and the effects of the ghost would often
be connected to the way they died
if you have trouble breathing maybe
that's a ghost who died by strangulation
or by Drowning do you have a terrible
fever maybe you're haunted by a ghost
who died in a fire
ghosts were again spirits of the Dead
who had not quite moved on to the
underworlds or in more Sinister examples
might have been summoned by a
necromancer the job of The Exorcist in
these cases was to make sure the ghost
could make its way to that underworld
through reciting incantations and spells
it's all kind of similar to the way that
we conceive of ghosts today and the way
that they are portrayed in movies and so
on the ashipu as part of this ritual
could chant incantations that included
instructions like I implore you to
return to your true Abode in the
Underworld and then the ghost would
hopefully listen to him for example now
if your problems were rather caused by a
demon that was a more complicated matter
demons are not deceased human beings but
Immortal Spirits as we saw standing in
between Gods and Men
so unlike a witch or a ghost you
couldn't get rid of a demon by killing
it or destroying it this required more
complicated rituals in the case of La
Master the baby eating demon we
discussed before there were several ways
of getting rid of her
usually The Exorcist would use a
figurine of the Goddess herself which
became like a kind of receptable or body
for the actual demon the figurine could
be placed next to the victim or in
general kept in the House Then followed
several days of ritual the figurine
would be taken care of even perhaps fed
and such things almost in way to show
hospitality and get the demon on your
good side
The Exorcist would throughout these days
recite incantations and perform various
rituals
all the effects of the rituals performed
upon the figurine were transferred to
the demon herself so to say so the the
figure of this demon just like when you
pray to a god in various polytheistic
religions were seen as the kind of as as
embodying the demon and what you did to
the Statue of the figurine affected the
actual Spirit herself lastly then after
these days of rituals the figurine would
be taken away and buried outside the
city walls together with another
figurine of a black dog thus one had
banished lamashtu in the case of this
demon s we also often see the employment
of Pazuzu that other demon as a
protective force in these rituals in
connection to rituals like these or just
in themselves for preventive or
productive reasons The Exorcist could
also make amulets that would protect the
prison
amulets could look in different ways and
be made up of various materials and
their contents developed across the
history of Mesopotamia for the most part
amulets in Mesopotamia were so-called
unleathered or semi-lettered amulets in
other words they didn't necessarily have
anything written on them or inscribed on
them lettered amulets would appear later
in Egyptian and Roman contexts and
adopted a Mesopotamia through that but
in the earlier period this was usually
not the case an amulet could be a little
bag made of animal hire that contained
some sort of natural material like a
plant or something that was considered
protective or the object could be
infused with its protective Powers
through incantations vocally recited
over it by The Exorcist it could then be
worn around the neck or hung above the
door or bed of someone you wanted to
keep safe again in the case of La Master
we saw that one very popular amulet was
to wear a figurine of the head of the
demon Pazuzu who protected against her
evil Powers the Spells and incantation
used by The ashipur Exorcist could vary
also depending on the particular
circumstance or spirit that one worked
with but in most cases they take the
form of seeking help from the gods
praising them before asking for the
specific favor and ending with a promise
to fulfill if help is granted as I said
in later periods we also see the
prominence of written talismans where
images or spells will be written on an
object like a piece of parchment or
copper or stone and just the fact that
those words are written on it means it
has protective powers
a common spell could look like this
quote First there would be the word an
which means spell and then it would say
the actual spell like like this
daughter of Anu prominent one among the
gods in in most princely lady but also
binder Grievous asako demon ghost that
weighs heavily upon mankind so that
exalted La Master should not come close
to man may you be bound by the spell of
Heaven Bound by the spell of Earth
this kind of thing becomes incredibly
widespread in later periods we see a
very extravagant examples of this in the
so-called Babylonian incantation bowls
of late Antiquity these were often
conceived in a Jewish context but
functioned in the same way rabbinic or
Biblical verses could be written in
these bowls which then function to trap
evil demons it's fascinating stuff and
the later Islamic tradition and there
are called practices we see the exact
same things with quranic verses or names
of God in Arabic being employed as
talismans by simply writing them down on
different materials
some argue that many of these practices
have their origins in ancient
Mesopotamia as a third example maybe you
are being bothered by the malevolent
magic of witches or ashaptu this is a
little different from demons because
witches can be killed the ritual of
getting rid of a witch is somewhat
similar to a demon exorcism though the
ashipu would often make a figurine of
the witch and rituals performed on the
figurine would transfer to the actual
rich just like in the case with LA
Master for example
in a similar fashion incantations were
recited and then the figurine was often
burned in a fire so that the witch's
Spirit would rise like smoke to the
heavens and be punished by the gods and
even more mundane problems could be
solved with the help of these ritual
Specialists perhaps you got stung by a
scorpion a pretty serious thing in the
ancient Middle East one instruction
sounds like this quote a bundle of seven
Reeds to be used as a torch then the
Scorpion will be placed on the burning
torch until it is consumed during that
time one will recite Over The Sting the
prayer as follows and then there follows
a longer prayer which ends like this
then let the flowing water carry
everything away in its Eddies let the
current take it away and may a solitary
hand that of envel descend to rest on
its victim such is the formula to calm
the effects of the sting of a scorpion
indeed these are just a few examples of
the different ways that the ashipur the
ritual Specialist or Exorcist would help
people with various evil forces or
demons and spirits in ancient
Mesopotamia but as we saw this was an
accepted reality this was part of
everyday life for people and calling for
an exorcist was basically the same as us
calling for a doctor today the lands of
Babylon and Assyria of Sumer and akkad
were filled with spooky ghosts and
spirits and creatures which sometimes
could cause you illnesses or other
problems and the only way to get rid of
those problems was to call a ritual
specialist an ashipu or Exorcist that
could use his specialized knowledge and
the tools that he had at his disposal to
get rid of the issue some of this we
recognize very clearly from our modern
conception of these things from how
ghosts work to demons and exorcisms but
we should also be careful not to project
are modern ideas onto a context in
ancient times that was very different a
lot of these Concepts and ideas have a
different meaning to the ancient
Mesopotamians than they perhaps do to us
today but at the very least it remains a
fascinating tradition of occult practice
a fascinating tradition of ancient
religion that not only can tell us a lot
about the development of these kinds of
ideas all the way to modern times but
also of course fits perfectly into this
wonderful yearly tradition of shocktober
here on let's talk religion as I said in
the beginning this is a collaboration
with three other creators again Dr
Justin Sledge from esoterica who will be
making a video about the dibik the very
famous kind of possessing uh spirit of
Judaism and especially or particularly
he will be talking about the first case
of dybic exorcism in the I believe the
16th century and that's incredibly
fascinating and of course connected to
what we talk about here so I'll have
talked just now about ancient exorcism
the earliest examples of exorcistic
rituals in ancient Mesopotamia and
Justin will be talking about how that
tradition is also present to some degree
in Judaism with the case of the dybic so
check out that video Dr Angela puka from
Angela Symposium will be making a video
about ancestor worship again very
strongly connected to a lot of what
we've been talking about here today uh
incredibly interesting stuff so check
out that video and then a trail aka the
modern hermeticist will basically be
putting out a full audiobook of a 17th
century translation of the arbatel of
magic a fast knitting grimoire from the
16th century about ceremonial magic so
do not miss out on those incredibly
fascinating videos by some amazingly
talented creators and friends and
amazing human beings go to their
channels there will be links in the
description to all of that stuff to
their videos and to their channels go
watch the videos go subscribe to their
channels you will not regret it it is
truly some really awesome
content here on YouTube I hope this
video was a good introduction to some of
the earliest examples of magic some of
the earliest examples of occult
practices and in particular exorcisms
and demons in ancient Mesopotamia this
is such a interesting topic to to
research and talk about I just love
doing this stuff and especially on a
October evening like this look forward
to more episodes in this year's October
next week we are talk talking about the
Sham Selma Arif the most famous and I
should say Infamous book of
occult
practices in the history of the Islamic
and arabic speaking world so I will see
you then